native aldi has five consecutive no
decisions the red sox have won all five
as he's at 10 wins he's been stuck there
a while
that was pretty nasty and mr mullins
goes down hacking on the splitter well i
guess that didn't take very long good
morning good afternoon and see you later
line drive won't get at this inning
that's a base hit
around first brian castle puts on the
brakes and the orioles have a base
runner here with one down in the first
ryan mount castle hit his 30th homer
yesterday comes out swinging today
wave dad and missed and he puts away
another one he strikes on santander
swinging into this struck him out back
to the split
he strikes out three in the first inning
red sox coming up and alexander wells
first time he's faced the red sox first
time he has uh experienced fenway park
under 258 28 home runs he'll suck a base
hit into right field
hernandez trots into second red sox
coming at him right away first and
second nobody out
first and second nobody out
and they'll pop that one in the left
center racing out as martin he can't get
to it it dunks down for a hit hernandez
had to hold up to see if it might be
caught so he's going to stay at third
and they're going to be loaded for
xander right away base is full of red
sox a ball and two strikes nobody down
pitch to bogarts
he got him went upstairs one down well
that's my point about if you get ahead
you can and we saw him do this against
aaron judge you can expand the strike
zone up in the zone
wells trying to work out of a mess
struck out bogarts now 2-2 on the way to
martinez he got him looking
hit that outside corner jd doesn't agree
doug eddings the home plate umpire
punches him out two down bobby dulberg
trying to salvage the inning now 247 23
home runs and he's gonna get drilled and
that'll bring in a run kk to come on in
to score how about that wells gets that
kind of a gift he's this close to
getting out of the inning and he drills
a guy so here is plawicki with the bases
loaded hitting at 281. two homers 12
runs batted in
bounding ball and that's going to find a
hole to the right side
one run
in denver's now coming in as the throw
gets to third they're gonna man in a run
down another run scores
and delbeck will be tagged out but the
red sox grab a couple of more on the
base hit by plawecki
and leaded three to nothing after an
inning at fenway
3-2
and strike three
97 with the swifty that ball looked like
it was rising to the top of the zone
he's fan four
looked like he went yes he did
got him with the slider got him to
commit
two more k's in the inning for nate [ __ ]
with a walk and a run to get it going in
the first inning
swinging that one ripped toward the wall
down the left-field line and that's a
fair ball another one is in verdugo
scores
kiki jumped all over it for his 54th run
batted in red sox on top four nothing
this ball just sneaks in fair
two men on for anthony santander one out
in the top of the third
two two to santander
lying down the left field line that's a
fair ball
into the corner
mullins in to score
birds on the board and anthony santander
has an rbi a little action from austin
here with two out
oh two up the middle and into center
field that'll get two in
austin hayes delivers the action with
two down
mount castle santander score and it's a
one-run game that brings up jd martinez
martinez took a call third strike in the
first inning red sox four baltimore
three there's a high fly ball into left
that's way up there
santander turning looking that is into
the monster seats home run
jd with number 27 his 94th run batted in
he had enough and the red sox lead it
five to three boy this ball was in the
air a long time got a curveball and then
lift off
walks him
good speed on
what are we doing here well of course
coming out with a trainer yeah what's
going on here
something's up here with woodlock
he's going to take him out he's coming
out man they are all over it right away
his last pitch
looks like something with the chest huh
yeah he reached for something there but
sarmora had been warming and heating up
so in he comes loads the bases for trey
mancini
hirokazu salwamura bases loaded first
pitch trey mancini he swings this gets
past the diving rafale divers one run
will score two runs will score santander
around third he gets the green light
he's in frey mancini clears the bases
for the orioles they take a six to five
lead in the seventh
and [ __ ] with an rbi opportunity red sox
trying to tie it right away
he's already ripped a double to score a
run
that was in the second inning so red sox
finally get a hit
for the first time since the third
up the middle and that's off the back
a run is in it ricochets into the
outfield
and the red sox tie it
on ricochet six six
hundred on the day one for three a
single run he's flied out and popped up
since then
and green zone swung on high fly ball
left field that one is up there it is up
off the wall
kk churning into third gonna wave him in
here's the throw home and not gonna get
him and the socks are back in front
renfro
off the monster to play [ __ ]
and the socks are in front seven to six
rafael devers steps in against cole
sulzer
ground ball open space that should bring
in another run
renfro turns he's home
and another rbi for rafael devers number
105.
now the sox have some wiggle room
the third gonna be a tough play
gutierrez he got him what a play
well they they all seem to be what a
play
one two from richards
struck him out paint me you bad tapper
[Applause]
red sox leading eight to six in the
ninth
and a high chop
devers has it that should do it
and the red sox make it five in a row
they are hot at a great time and they
sweep baltimore